vendredi au conseil général des yvelines
déjà dans les têtes les élections
départementales des 22 et 29 mars
prochain avec une nouvelle règle il n'ya
plus 39 mais 21 cantons il n'y a plus un
conseiller général par canton mais un
binôme composé d'un homme et d'une femme
soit 42 élus la fédération ump des
yvelines vient de dévoiler une grande
partie des candidats en lice avec une
volonté d'union dès le premier tour avec
lui des i pour faire barrage au front
national
notre volonté est de faire un barrage
parce que dans ce pays et grammatico
aujourd'hui c'est que toutes les
formations de gauche ont l'air d'être
très diminuée électoralement parlant ça
veut dire que si la droite ne s'unit pas
avec le centre et si nous ne faisons pas
feront dès le premier tour qu'est-ce qui
se passe vous ouvrez la porte au front
national qui n'attend que ça il n'en est
pas question
autre objectif avoué à demi-mot faire le
grand chelem
certains cantons sont actuellement
détenues par la gauche c'est le cas du
canton de trappes jeanine marie
candidate sortante va se trouver opposé
au maire d'elancourt jean michel
fourgous
vu la situation d'abord des du crédit
budgétaire des trois communes et bien
sûr qu'il est urgent je pense d'aller
accrocher ce canton des trois communes
la verrière trappe
ils encourent à la majorité
départementale ce que si vous voulez des
aides des moyens il faut être dans la
majorité
moi je relève le défi et j'y vais on va
voir maintenant si tu es si je perds je
l'assumerai vous inquiétez pas mais
voilà il ya je pense qu'il ya deux ans
avec la commune et l'encours qui peut il
fonctionner responsables des locaux
qu'ils y aillent pour effectivement
tenté cependant qu'il est effectivement
très difficile d'accès mais je pense que
dans cette
situation territoriale avec là encore un
nouveau redécoupage la personnalité de
jean michel peut faire la différence
c'est un candidat commun entre tous
candidats méritent d'être respectés
moi je reste pas je tiens à ce qu'on
respecte mes convictions je respecte
aussi celle des autres toutes les
campagnes sont ardues et aucune n'est
jamais gagné d'avancé
ils vendent vale sera candidat sur le
canton de maurepas son binôme n'est pas
encore connue mais son suppléant si il
s'agit de grégory gare et astier le
nouveau maire de maurepas mort passé la
commune la plus importante du canton il
nouveau canton donc il ya une certaine
logique
et puis ya aussi la volonté clairement
d'amorcer un renouvellement génération
travailler ensemble ça va être
l'occasion pour lui de faire un tuilage
progressivement d'apprendre
effectivement ce qu'elle conseil général
son mode de fonctionnement
après je pense qu'effectivement il sera
prêt je suis les responsabilités de
conseil général un jour prochain à
rambouillet la question n'est pas encore
tranchée christine boutin ne sait pas si
elle sera ou pas candidate
je suis en train de réfléchir ma
décision n'est pas prise définitivement
pour savoir si je repars ou pas donc
j'ai demandé à l'ump de réserver ce
canton j'ai l'habitude de transmettre et
donc voilà donc je réfléchis encore un
peu de temps encore il faut voir qui
peut se présenter et comment on peut
assurer la véritable pérennité et la
transmission de tout ce que j'ai essayé
de faire dans ce territoire je pas qui
s'y passe n'importe quoi christine
boutin donnera sa position en début
d'année autres quand on vous la
fédération départementale a réservé sa
décision
celui de montigny le bretonneux le
canton est pour l'heure détenu par le
maire de guyancourt le socialiste
françois de ligne et c'est un problème
de profil c'est un problème de non c'est
un problème de décision parce que vous
ne propulse est pas quelqu un comme ça
pour être élue je peux là nous parlons
du binôme
c'est à dire de ceux qui deviendront
conseillers généraux dans les autres
cantons de notre secteur philippe
benassaya nouveau maire de bois d'arcy
sera candidat sur le canton de saint cyr
l'école à plaisir bertrand cocarde et y
fera équipe avec joséphine cold case
berger la mère de plaisir reste une
interrogation la participation à ces
départementale est traditionnellement ce
ne sont pas les élections qui mobilise
plus